et une nouvelle augmentation puisque je
faisais des oeuvres beaucoup plus
colosse et c'est toujours dans la
réflexion aussi que je suis dans dans
cette faiblesse est évident que j'ai
moins d'énergie à donner à donner sous
des oeuvres qui sont encore lancé je me
mets à travailler beaucoup plus petit et
pour faire tout le monde et profiter les
oeuvres puisqu'il y en a beaucoup qui
m'ont demandé des heures pour rentrer
chez eux et puis pour aussi à la bouche
aussi cette oeuvre qui est derrière qui
s'appelle l'élévation de ces innovations
du christ qui monte au ciel
moi c'est une réflexion que j'ai que
j'avais depuis 25 ans qui est endormi en
moi et puis il ya longtemps je me posais
cette question et la montée du christ
c'est vers le ciel comme enjeu la
représenter et là j'ai pris cette
réflexion à le mettre sur un panneau de
4 cm et une largeur de 60 60 cm et qui
qui l'y accompagner avec 6,7
c'est peut être étanche en montant vers
le ciel
rien n'y fit et tim roth vers le haut et
ne qui redonne côté punk qui condamne
vers le bas alors sept panneaux et fait
1 2 face les mêmes les mêmes des
sculptures je suis je suis un peu
réunion à mon travail est moins
personnellement
rebellyon un peu sur tout mais
intérieurement mais les pannes rebelles
qui ressorte d'une violence mais nous
rebelles de méfiance est entièrement est
venu que je fais beaucoup de beaucoup de
travail beaucoup de choses que je fais
et quand quelque chose ne va pas je me
rebelle en moi même personnellement et
c'est lors d'un autre chose et puis le
revend le rebelle rappelle un petit peu
césaire
aussi aussi c'est à cause parce qu'il y
en a il faut dire qu'un étude de chevet
ou 7 se rebelle j'ai fait une étude du
cheveu
c'est souvent je faisais des chez lui
dire comment je vais me représenter ses
cheveux en sculpture alors j'ai fait les
cheveux gris nez et long d'une demi long
et qui du coup c'est la création du
champ du cheveu et tout ça dans changer
vos cheveux puisque c'est sous le crâne
ce au niveau du cerveau de ce qu'on
pense c'est ce qu'on a envie de faire